how's it going everybody welcome back to
the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and we've gotten a ton of Fantastic Four
casting news reports rumors you name it
we've gotten it all and we've gotten a
lot of it recently but it looks like
things are finally getting locked down
over at Marvel Studios for the fantastic
boardcast and what's really interesting
is that we know because it's been
reported on for a while now that Marvel
Studios wanted to cast Sue storm first
they wanted to cast Sue's storm and then
build the rest of the Fantastic Four
team Around Sue or rather the actress
who was going to be playing Sue they'll
build the rest of the cast around her
looks her personality her energy and
essentially the way that she herself
will be depicted as Sue storm and it
looks like not only has Sue Storm been
locked in but Johnny Storm might have
been locked in as well and considering
the information that we know about what
Marvel Studios wanted with Sue building
the family around her it makes sense
that they would choose her brother as as
well but we also have another really big
update about Mr Fantastic and apparently
a new script for the Fantastic Four and
this is big news and I believe a really
great sign because Marvel Studios what
they've been doing recently is kind of
evaluating everything they've done and
especially right now with all the
strikes going on they can take a step
back and look at what they currently
have what they're currently making and
go is this good or not but Kevin feige
the president of Marvel Studios made it
very clear they're changing the way they
do some stuff at Marvel Studios and at
Disney they're gonna release fewer
Disney Plus shows so they can focus on
movies and making them all shows and
movies better but they were doing this
actually before they made that Disney
plus decision they rewrote the entire
script of Blade because they thought it
was terrible and mahershala Ali himself
complained about it and thought it was
bad as well and that could be perhaps
something that is going on here with
them revising the Fantastic Four script
writing a new one but we'll break down
everything you need to know in this
video about who the cast members could
be right now and what this new script
could mean and if you love Marvel be
sure to subscribe so you can stay up to
date on all the latest MCU news and so
you can enter our giveaway for a chance
to win an Xbox series X A PS5 some
Marvel Legends items or some DC items
the winner gets to pick one item and we
pick a winner at the end of each month
so here's what's really interesting
about the new Fantastic Four script the
original script that they had for the
MCU reboot of the Fantastic Four was
written by Jeff Kaplan and Ian Springer
and they are known for comedy and there
are definitely some big comedic aspects
involved with the Fantastic Four
especially in the previous adaptations
however Josh Friedman on the other hand
is pretty different his work is pretty
much known to be sci-fi he co-wrote War
of the Worlds with Steven Spielberg and
Tom Cruise starred in that movie he was
also a writer for the Terminator the
Sarah Connor Chronicles show and then
Terminator dark fade in 2019 but one of
his biggest accomplishments is that he
helped James Cameron in creating stories
for the Avatar franchise so very
different styles of tone between the
original writers and the new Rider and
what we've heard is that Marvel Studios
wants Adam Driver to play Mr Fantastic
of the Fantastic Four however Adam
Driver apparently turned it down because
he could not relate to the character he
could not relate to Reed Richards so we
turned the role down but according to
many different insiders Marvel Studios
still wants him for the role and
according to a recent report from
Insider Daniel rbk Marvel Studios is
going to meet with him again after the
strikes are over and they're going to
present him with a new Fantastic Four
script this means a great deal because
clearly they think that the script is
different enough for Adam Driver to
possibly consider playing Mr Fantastic
even though he turned down the role
before Adam Driver isn't particularly
known for big comedic roles in fact he's
really known for his more sci-fi roles
like kylo Ren or him playing the lead in
the movie 65 or his very serious role in
the last duel so a new script with a
more serious Reed Richards might appeal
to him a little bit more than the old
script than the old read Richards that
they had planned for the Marvel
Cinematic Universe and don't get me
wrong he can and has played comedic
roles but Reed Richards is kind of a
serious character of course he can be
funny and he is sometimes in the comics
but don't forget he is the smartest man
alive and also the smartest man in the
Marvel Comics universe and it's also
worth noting that his and his wife of
course Sue storm The Invisible Woman
their daughter is the third smartest
character in Marvel Comics Valeria
Richards but again perhaps this is
something that he could relate to a
little bit more Marvel clearly thinks so
which is why they want to meet with him
again after the strike is over to try
and show him the new script to see if he
relates more to the new Reed Richards
that they have written for the movie and
for the MCU as a whole so this is big
news this means that the script has
changed and the tone of the movie has
most likely changed as well perhaps
given us more of a serious Vibe rather
than a comedic Vibe again don't get me
wrong that doesn't mean the movie can't
be funny after all it is a Marvel film
and they always have a big comedic
aspect to their films but since they're
coming into the Multiverse Saga and
they're going to have to deal with a
threat like Kang we can definitely see a
more serious tone for the film so right
now as far as we know Mr Fantastic is
not locked down because Marvel Studios
wants to talk to Adam Driver once again
but it seems like we know two characters
who are completely locked in see storm
and her brother Johnny Storm we'll talk
about them in just a bit but if you want
to learn more about the Fantastic Four
from the comics be sure to check out our
partners over at comicbookdirect.com
they have created a website and company
that makes comic book shopping the
easiest it can possibly be they deliver
Comics straight to your door you can get
one-off Comics or you can sign up for an
entire run and get a pretty big discount
if you do so and they'll ship the latest
issue right to your door each week they
have the latest from Marvel if you're
trying to keep up to date with all the
recent projects they have the latest
from DC as well and it's an all-in-one
shop for your Comics everything that you
need in one place you can sign up for a
membership to get free shipping and a
mystery box each month and the next 100
people to sign up get 20 off their first
order using the link in the description
down below so we've all heard this for a
while but it does seem like Vanessa
Kirby has been given an offer to play
Sue storm by Marvel and has accepted
that offer and this has come from
multiple different Insider sources and
since they all seem to agree that they
have all heard the same information it
does seem like this is indeed locked in
Vanessa Kirby is our Sue storm and the
other character that seems to be locked
in right now like I mentioned is Johnny
Storm her brother and the actor who was
supposedly locked in for that role is
Joseph Quinn now this isn't as 100 as
Vanessa Kirby locked in for her role but
there is concept art that came out
recently for the Fantastic Four the new
Fantastic Four and Joseph Quinn is
featured in that concept art that is why
many different people believe that he
could possibly be fully locked in for
the role Marvel might have given him an
offer and he might have accepted it
already since he is in some concept art
and his name has been reported as
somebody who Marvel Studios wants to
play Johnny Storm it all seems to kind
of line up and point to him being cast
as Johnny Storm now that might not be
official because of the strikes right
now that could be the only reason why he
might not be officially locked in but
again right now all signs point to him
being our Johnny Storm and the brother
of Vanessa Kirby's Sue storm and like I
mentioned in the beginning we know that
Marvel wanted to cast Sue first and
build the cast around her so that
actually leaves me a question for you
all do you think Vanessa Kirby would go
well with Adam Driver as Mr Fantastic
there have been other actors rumored to
have been offered the role like Matt
Smith do you think he would be better
working alongside of Vanessa Kirby or do
you think Adam Driver is the person that
needs to play Mr Fantastic let us know
your thoughts about this in the comments
down below who would you like to see
play Mr Fantastic again the Fantastic
Four in the MCU and what do you think
the tone of the film should be do you
think it should be a comedy do you think
it should be more serious or a mixture
of both let us know everything all your
thoughts in the comments down below and
don't forget to like the video and
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest videos don't forget to
follow us on Instagram and Twitter as
well and as always thank you all so much
for watching woof woof